earlier this year Facebook's audacious
stratospheric solar-powered internet be
me drone Aquila flew for the first time
but it's not delivering cat videos just
yet Facebook still needs a way of
connecting the drone to the internet so
company engineers in Southern California
are working to build new forms of
communication using more conventional
planes we are testing on airborne
communication technology that can enable
up to 20 gigabits per second to the
ground and joining gigabits per second
up that's 400 times faster than most
home internet connections 20 gigabits
per second is equivalent to about a
thousand 4k streams live streams going
on simultaneously it's the sort of
bandwidth that could deliver the
Internet across dozens of miles to a fly
in Aquila then the drone could beam the
signal straight down to areas that
aren't already online via developing
technologies that extends the
connectivity out to the rural areas this
has never been done before so Tiwari and
his team are building an entirely new
kind of communications technology so
putting a high-capacity long-range
communication payload on a solar-powered
UAV is a very unique technical challenge
to worry at his team are attaching a
gimbal stabilized antenna to the belly
of this Cessna at the heart of this
setup is an old but subtly resurgent
communications frequency called
millimeter wave the amount of bandwidth
that is available in some of these
millimeter wave bands make it possible
to create very high capacity and
multiple tens of gigabits per second
data rates over these wireless
communication links once a loss they
track the plane from the roof of their
Southern California offices Oh
one of Facebook's challenges is building
the system robust enough to not only
stay aloft but also deliver the sort of
bandwidth an entire community on the
ground might need that will mean
multiple drones all connected together
the ground station has to communicate to
the air station in upwards of 30
gigabits per second 40 gigabits per
second over a range of 30 to 40
kilometers once it gets to the UAV the
two UAVs could have a separation of up
200 to 300 kilometres we are developing
free space optics links that would
interconnect these pillars that are
flying at that high altitude for data
rates exceeding a 50 gigabit specific
Facebook isn't the only company
interested in airborne internet Google
and Airbus have both dabble with their
own high altitude communication systems
but Facebook sees Aquila as more than
just eyes in the sky or broadband for
the rural masses
and also become a critical tool in a
disaster company plans to make the
technology open source so anyone from a
telecom to a disaster response
organization could deploy it
imagine hurricane comes through and
bites out the infrastructure you could
set up and deploy a solar powered UAV
within hours and everyone can use the
connectivity services to tell their
friends and family or all around the
world that they're okay that's a nod a
facebook safety check system an online
tool that is changing the way we deal
with disaster response the rub is that
Facebook is still years away from
building a version of Aquila that could
be deployed in the real world subsequent
generations of this technology will
focus on reducing the DC power
consumption and the mass and the drag
but when Aquila finally takes to the
skies it could forever change the way we
communicate not only in the developing
world but during the most trying times